story maker what what is that story
maker was born out of the land of
blocked writers and it's a 90-minute
process that gives you prompts basically
to to develop a character-driven story
based on anything you could take pickles
airplanes hotel and because we've live
in stories we watch stories we're so
immersed in storytelling it's in our DNA
and if you can stop thinking and just
allow your reaction to go forward you
will develop a story I'm not saying
it'll be a great story but it'll be a
story and it'll have a beginning middle
end and it'll have characters who change
and dilemmas that'll be interesting in a
genre that you're that could attract an
audience but these simple props when you
when you start just allowing your first
reaction to to come forward you'll start
to feel how powerful your internal
storytelling clock is and I have more
much more confidence in it and so that's
the that's the reason that I came up
with this process because the other
thing is as writers we practice dialogue
we practice scenes right we practice all
these things but no one practices the
art of telling an entire story so if I
can get you in ninety minutes to tell an
entire story beginning middle and end
good or bad we don't know but beginning
middle and end in 90 minutes you could
do that once a week which means you
could have 52 stories at the end of the
year and how many good stories do you
think you'd have if you had 52 stories
every year probably more than you have
now
and you would also be building an
incredible muscle of developing ideas of
being able to solve story problems of
knowing how characters change of knowing
your genres about knowing your ups and
downs of
rhythm of a story and it would just
become part of you and you wouldn't even
have to think about it and so that's my
goal for writers to really learn this as
a dance like you would learn the tango
and learn to dance this story without
even thinking
you